hey guys for I start today's episode
just want to let you know so you know
you'll see in the episode I change
search if you're watching on YouTube
because I started the episode and then I
had to go do the pot then I had a good
do the show in Raleigh my last show on
Sunday night and then had to come back I
know maybe you guys don't care but when
I realize all is that the show was at
you know I hadn't taken my
antidepressants in about three tomorrow
morning will be my fourth day and some
of you guys if you don't take
antidepressants you don't care you don't
know that's fine
but for me man you know I get kind of
chirped out you know I'm fine but let's
get a little bit of it you know I get a
little bit of emo Nemo you know I start
kind of swimming around in my feelings
too much so it's not a disclaimer or
anything but I did notice you know
before I was leaving for the show that I
was just kind of you know just kind of
stressed out she's been a long week and
then when you don't have that support
your training wheels are gone and can
get a little tricky but I love you guys
and let's get into the episode today's
episode is brought to you by grey block
pizza gray block for that pizza that you
need today's episode is also brought to
you by our sponsor beard brand beer
brand it's a premium men's grooming
company and they got products for your
skin your face your beard your hair and
your body they have a utility balm
product that if you want to maybe you
have a tattoo that needs to be you know
kind of softened up or tightened up or
whatever or even soft tightened at the
same time maybe you are a by cyclist and
your face gets chapped in certain spaces
and you got a you know moisten that skin
up maybe you have chapped spots under
your eyes maybe you stay a real hard at
stuff and you need to moisten those
hitters you know you got to moisten up
the little vision balls
well the utility balm can do that they
have a sea salt spray it's a texturizing
hair product and you hit get it up in
your Mane you lion up give that volume
give that texture if you go in Africa or
you're going somewhere if you even going
outdoors and you want animals to look
over at you to and to know that you
working with Poseidon himself get that
sea salt spray put it in your hair they
also have a styling balm it's got a
medium holdin a set and finish
and you can check them out beard
brand.com slash Theo actually and you'll
get that free sea salt spray
automatically added to your order while
supplies last so get on there get that
hit or we'll put the link below if you
want to use their products and you want
to try them out I'll tell you this I've
tried them I've used them and I like
them and you might also all right let's
get that hitter live from Raleigh North
Carolina Rolly Rolly Rolly let's let's
rely on ourselves to get through get
through this this episode onward baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was made
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go there's Jameson flood with
every night every night I lie awake
every night I put on a I feel like a
fake I put on a show interesting lines
there you know interesting lyrics
interesting notes for years boy
interesting little soundbites just
things that think about you know what's
going on I'm here from Raleigh North
Carolina
dude I'm this one's coming to you by
sunlight I put this thing up by sunlight
usually I'll put up the lamps and I take
this thing in the evening but I still
have another show to do I got a show I
got to be at and literally I'll be on
stage in one hour from now so a lot of
you guys are like well it's gonna be a
short episode it might be it might be
that tiny dancer you know this might be
a mouse you know this might not be a
lemur this might not be a leopard this
might be a mouse but it might be a
circus mouse
oh well yeah you might have a little bit
of a circus mouse because some people
you know a lot of mice can't do this
shows and a lot of mice are powerful you
know and if a mice gets electrocuted
enough he could be a rat so sometime you
don't need that Leopard you think you
need that leper but you need that
[ __ ] shifty Mouse sometime you get
that Mouse that little Brazilian Jujitsu
[ __ ] little you know that dirty
little [ __ ] marsupial you know that
crafty little [ __ ] cheese snacker
think about it dude a mouse a lot of
people talk about fancy animals you know
they talk about you know everybody's all
talking about the polar bears and [ __ ]
like that
animals we don't even see bro we don't
know anything about the polar bears dude
what are you talking about there's a
couple pictures of them their hair is
always yellow because I guess a lot of
them look like this I think they smoke
cigarettes
you know so the a lot of the smoke gets
like gets on your mustache like your
granddaddy used to have when he you know
blow them Winston's and that smoke would
get all you know I'm saying if you
didn't have a granddaddy with a yellow
mustache and a little bit of like green
tinge on his cheeks then maybe uh maybe
you didn't have a real granddaddy but
yeah man a lot of animals their fancy
animals out there you know a lot of big
animals and people talk about you know
chimpanzees you know bonobos you know uh
meerkats and the like you know Komodo
dragons but a lot of people they don't
nobody wants to give credit to a mouse
think about a [ __ ] Mouse dude a mouse
um dude a mouse could be anywhere right
now what's in your sofa what's living in
your sofa a [ __ ] leopard doubt it
maybe a mouse you know a mouse have so
many small practices Mouse love cheese
we love cheese you don't think there's
some you know you could you you have so
much more you can relate to a mouse so
much more than you can so many other
animals sometimes you get scared mice
get scared you know mice don't like cats
a lot of people don't like cats you know
but sometimes you want these big animals
you want these fancy hitters but all you
need is that Mouse you need something
small you need something you just need
something you know you got to keep it
small aim small miss small you know I
don't want to keep it big I'm trying to
stay focused it's been nice here in
Raleigh Raleigh well first of all you
guys should have a meeting and decide
how you're gonna pronounce your city
Raleigh Raleigh
some guys said it like that I'm like
dude that's not a name you got [ __ ]
dude you got a dole as my son you might
have water in your lungs baby you got
them [ __ ] Titanic's in your chest do
your [ __ ] syncing
you know I'm saying you might want to
tell the band to keep playing cuz you
[ __ ] goin down with your own [ __ ]
with your own breathe ship you know you
you got them [ __ ] in ur body bags as
those uh those breaths shuttles and your
shits filling up with water
he's like welcome to Raleigh North
Carolina my bro you need to get checked
out or you don't even need to get
checked out just know that your [ __ ] is
uh you got some [ __ ] interior leaks
going on
you know just know that when you have a
glass of water probably got 6% of it
ends up in your lungs just know how you
know know what your intake is like but
it's been nice here what's been going on
you know sometimes I get amped up and
sometimes I get more amped down you know
sometimes I get like a tiger sometimes I
feel like a UH like a loud animal and
sometimes I just feel a little bit more
like a mouse you know and I like being a
mouse I think you know because a mouse
you know a squeak is pretty specific a
mouse can't do make a lot of sounds you
know a mouse can make a squeak so you
have to be very you got to be specific
you got to try and be articulate you
know you have to try and be effective
you know people are ah I say people and
I'm real I say people I'm talking about
myself I just don't want to feel alone
so a lot of times I'll say people or
I'll say we but I man I think there's
gonna start to be people I hear I do it
again i I think that silence that peace
is guess that it's all gonna start to
become so much more of a commodity like
you know like back in the old days it
used to be like oh there's gold in those
hills over there and people would show
up to go get the gold but you know I
feel like in 10 years you need like oh
there's a there's a there's no
advertisements over in those hills over
there or there's no um you know no no
there's no you know backhanded marketing
over there in that cave over there
there's no loud noises that you don't
want there's no constant music constant
sounds constant just loudness there's
peace of mind over there that's gonna
that's the new gold that peace of mind
you know used to be a gold mine am i any
announced peace of mind I'm saying I'm
being there all day with a pickaxe just
trying to get a [ __ ] moment of
solitude a moment of silence a moment of
just a moment of that a moment of mouse
cuz man they got it's a lot of tigrin
it's a lot of tiger and they got a lot
of false tigers out there scratching at
you and trying to get our attention they
got a lot of you know crazy cats over
here dancing and dancing next thing I've
been watching this cat for tears and
this cat him doing anything for me but
here I am yelling at you and I'm not
trying to preach about things I don't
know what I'm thinking about when you
get down here in the south man and you
get lifted up you get the spirit this is
Andy Griffith country a lot of people
don't know Andy Griffith he was uh he
was from not um Mount Airy oh where is
he from Andy Griffith he's from I
believe it's RA how he pronounced it
Andy ll he's from right around here he
went to UNC he's from Mount Airy North
Carolina Andy Griffith he had he had a
children Andy Griffith jr. and Dixie and
Dixie Griffith and he died in Manteo
North Carolina July 3rd and he was born
in June and he died in July and so you
know he was a he must have been a shot
of light and a shot of warmth cuz he
showed up in the summer and left in the
summer and that wasn't a winner man but
Andy Griffith one of the best
storytellers ever you know you can still
find a lot of his stuff on YouTube and
if you really go looking
and some of my favorite storytellers
Jerry clower out of Yazoo City
Mississippi still one of the greatest
albums ever sold you go look on album
sold all time and it's a it was a small
man out of Yazoo Mississippi one of the
greatest storytellers of our time and
you know what I felt a little inspired
man you know I like telling stories and
I get inspire by men like that and Andy
Griffith then we went to the park I went
to the park over there with my buddy
Kevin my buddy sneaky Kevin showed up
and I t-shirt Kevin they called him and
I met him him and his brother were uh
you know drinking beer and playing skill
crane trying to win stuffed animals on a
cruise ship and I saw that man I said
damn boy you know and they're probably
in their 40s or even their 60s I don't
[ __ ] know bruh you know I'm saying
even when you look at him you know you
don't know what's going on with them
really you know Kalin directly you know
age wise but but I saw those two
gentlemen playing a skilled crane
drinking cambiar trying with stuff to
animals man and I said [ __ ] I got to
talk to these guys right here you know
cuz these guys are onto something these
guys are onto something trying to win a
real quiet little bear or a [ __ ] you
know a little pink giraffe man when they
in their 40s or 50s or 60s and their
brothers come and what's going on called
a cops bro call the cops cuz these boys
are coming in a little bit [ __ ] a
little bitty illegally yet the sun's
going down I'm looking out the window
right now I'm seeing some pine trees
dude they put me up in a fancy place
behind you just I turn on the [ __ ]
you ever turn on the faucet and you feel
bad the water's going down the drain
that's how this place is
you're like Tim that's [ __ ] the place
I'm staying at this place is rich man
they have curtains and then they have a
curtain outside of the curtain and then
they have a thick thick thick curtain I
don't know what that's for I think if
you're gonna kill somebody it's like a
Dexter it's like drawing them Dexter
shades do you come once you draw the the
heavy ones I mean these are some really
violent animals you know
it comes to curtains these are the
[ __ ] you know these are them you know
these are the when it comes to curtains
these are what are they like probably
they're probably like the dark night
these are the bane of curtains you know
these are some mmm when other curtains I
bet a lot of other curtains fold up when
they say the when they see these hitters
showing up and they uh yeah they got
three curtains so you could yeah in the
water the water looks so fresh out of a
tap yeah it's just going down the drain
you like [ __ ] I want a bucket this shut
up and take it out you know I might go
get me two it's some of some of those
big jugs that they have in office
buildings and um and I might take a lot
of this damn tap water home of ash it is
nice
do you ever been in a hotel room is so
expensive you I can't even sleep I said
[ __ ] this hotel room it's like $400 a
night sighing is sleeping [ __ ] if I
even sleep that's gonna cost me 160
bucks I'm just gonna stay up and at
least watch my money go buy this hotel
room is nice man they have a um they
have like uh they have phones in here
they have extra soap and the soap is all
wrapped up in like a little package like
damn like this soap won an award like
this [ __ ] soap on a SP you know I'm
saying like this little box like this
little bar of uh you know of lavender
eeeh
you know body wash this thing [ __ ]
caught a fly ball you know to win the to
win the championship it's yeah it's just
nice man it's a nice place out here and
so it's just a little different you know
I'm used to staying a little bit more
regular places but I'm grateful that
this club put me up and I'm grateful to
everybody that came out man we sold this
weekend out and you guys came out he you
know what I'll be honest sometimes I
don't really maybe flexing some of this
way but I'm gonna say this [ __ ] dude you
got a thank you for continuing to
support go support good comics don't let
these networks and this [ __ ] and you
know these talk shows that it's all paid
for and all these guests they try to
make it
authentic and it's not real don't let
them tell you what is funny
don't let them you know don't let them
they can influence you in entertainment
right they can influence you and they
can show you and you can have some joy
but don't when those people start
pushing their beliefs and stuff on you
that's when it gets scary you know
because then that's that bait-and-switch
so no I mean I mean maybe that's the
[ __ ] I do I don't know maybe I'm doing
the same I have no [ __ ] idea man but
I was just just I don't know I just feel
so much gratitude of people coming out
and you know cuz I worked my ass off I
love doing this job I love making people
feel good and I feel like it's a
responsibility that I have if I can do
it you know if I can make people laugh
and I can make you know you know that's
a gift I have I don't you know this is I
don't do I didn't make my world you know
I didn't create the world
I didn't bring myself and you know I
didn't bring myself into the world you
know I've been here navigating this
vessel I'm on you know with a lot of
help from my friends boy [ __ ] Bob
Seger country in my life or Jerry Seger
whatever the guys name is but [ __ ] I
forgot I was talking about dude damn and
I sometimes I hate thinking brah because
when you think dude if you start a
thought and you start talking do the
second I start talking I guess I get far
away from my thought then I'm just lost
brah I'm when it comes to chatting man
I'm like that Hansel and Gretel baby I
better take a couple of bags of bread
crumbs with me you know into a
conversation or anyway even a long
sentence because I don't know not know
where the [ __ ] I started
I guess I was just thinking yeah so many
people came out you know and it made me
feel good and if I have the ability to
make people laugh right then yeah that's
not my ability like it's you know it's
it's something that I do but it's not I
don't know I just feel like you know uh
I don't know I just feel I'm just
grateful people came out and and I'm
happy to be the one you know being one
of the comedians I'm happy to be the one
of the people doing it but yeah this is
somebody you know this is from a
different I'm just a conduit I've said
this before but I'm just you know I'm
just whatever's bringing if people are
laughs and I'm just you know part of the
river that's bringing that into the
world that's all I am you know and I
guess I just feel like when people come
out and but but you know like I just
want you know there's a lot I have a lot
of friends are great comedians that
don't get as much respect as they do
because you know a lot of these networks
and stuff they don't put them out there
they don't even know maybe you talk to
some of these executives they don't even
[ __ ] know I'm like you haven't heard
of this guy that guy's been killer for
nine years you don't know him but I'm
just saying you know we just got to make
our own choices and sometimes we have to
look past what's on the regular [ __ ] you
know we got to find out and people got
to send stuff to us and I don't know I
guess I'm getting preached you know I'm
sorry but it's been fun man I had so
much fun so many people came out people
came out they know how to do that flew
in is his birthday you know my dude just
got a couple years sober and he invited
me out to a meeting and I couldn't make
it cuz I've been sleeping well um we had
a single mom come out Nancy you know she
came out and she has uh she has a little
child a little two-year-old and you know
her sister brought her out and her
sister flew in just for the show to
bring her out to the show you know when
we treated her out and we're gonna take
care of her dinner and stuff like that
and you know next time I'm gonna have to
go with the single mom and the you know
and not in a lewd way you know I'm
trying I'm not trying to become that
step daddy unless I grow a sweet
mustache boy but but yeah
just cool man it's just there's so much
love going on in the building and I want
to thank our patreon supporters who
helped make that a reality the single
moms stuff and we're gonna we're gonna
start doing some other outreach stuff
I'm trying to find a business planner
who knows more about philanthrophy land
drop ik type of stuff so we can do some
more so we can do neat stuff you know
and I'm gonna get a cameraman in
different cities I'll say that now if
you're in a different city coming up and
you are know how to operate a camera
decently don't [ __ ] look if you show
up at a 35-millimeter or you show puss
you know up and some paints and [ __ ] we
ain't got time for that but you know if
you wanna do a production company or
something small like this in a big
budget thing but we'd love to be able to
create some you know cool video elements
of like you know maybe we take a single
mom out and do something fun for her do
something fun for the kids or I don't
know or do some other outreach ideas you
know um so we're gonna figure out some
more stuff but I'm gonna try to find a
businessperson who knows just a little
bit more how to do that because there's
only so much I can think about
without still being able to do you know
the work so anyway I don't know why I'm
talking about all this I'm not even
being entertaining but I'm sorry about
that I know this is an entertainment
podcast man I've been just all over the
place you haven't been sleeping well
since I got back from China I've just
been stressed out man you know it just
takes a lot of um you know and I'm
grateful everybody comes out but this I
never realized how much energy this
stuff you know a lot of this takes you
know and then I feel like a
responsibility you know like I guess and
maybe this is something that's wrong
with me you know I think this may be
some defect I have you noticed feel like
a responsibility too you know I guess
man I don't know this just got me
feeling it's just got me kind of
emotional and I don't know what I'm
talking about
I mean I just want to like you know
here's what I'm saying is like if I have
like you know say I have the ability to
do comedy or to tell stories or whatever
whatever it is man
you know or this gift whatever gift I
have that was given to me by whatever
higher powers are out there you know I
guess I just want to best be able to use
my ability to you know to do I guess
good stuff for to help other people and
I know I'm not trying to be cheesy or
anything but that's suddenly it becomes
for me like a lot of pressure you know
like I don't know you know and I know
I'm do I know I'm like being like you
know we do you know I know we're trying
to do like a lot of neat stuff but it's
just like it's just a lot man you know
and I got my producer Nick Davis and
Chris Perez and those dudes are working
they're you know they're not even
getting paid that much and you know
they're working way you know they're
working overtime everybody's work you
know it's but we want to do good stuff I
get I don't know what I'm saying man
just you know I guess I just want to
fail I don't want to fail myself but I
don't want to fail like whatever ability
that I have you know I don't want to
fail like whatever gifts or ability that
I have to do good or to be or to help
others I don't want to like I don't want
to like not be present to miss like an
opportunity to do that and and so I
guess suddenly I just been feeling like
a lot of fear like I don't know what I'm
doing you know because you do it for
years and and and people aren't you
don't see you you know you're just a
mouse and then people show up and
suddenly they and suddenly you feel like
you're supposed to be a cat I guess you
feel like you're supposed to be a
mountain lion you know we're all you
know aardvark that's you know also
[ __ ] doing some dirty [ __ ] on the
side and [ __ ] you know he's supposed
to be just doing an aardvark [ __ ] but
low key at night he's doing [ __ ] you
know
monkey type stuff and [ __ ] you know
you know dangerous animal [ __ ] you know
maybe hang gliding or something like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know butterfly
type activities but but yeah so then
people show up and you feel like you
know he's supposed to be a cat but then
I still feel like a mouse but then maybe
I just you know it's okay to be a mouse
I don't know it's just been a weird
[ __ ] week man I know this episodes
all over the place this is what happens
when I'm on the road when I'm not in the
studio dude I've been losing it you know
but literally like I get home and I have
enough sleep to like three or four you
know and then I wanted to go like I even
got a rental car this weekend my mother
went to Duke University and it's right
down the road from here and uh and she
graduated with honors you know I think
second in her class you know is so like
you know my whole life my mom's been
like a delivery person you know like um
she was in sales when I was real little
but then after that you know there's
delivering papers and delivering
magazines and all of that and so I guess
I don't know him [ __ ] man I'm getting
this it's you know wanted to go see her
college where she went to school because
I know she was like real proud of that
and then I didn't get to go because I
just haven't been able to sleep and then
I just haven't been feeling it so then
during the day I'm just stressed you
know it's like I'm just stressed and I'm
trying to sleep all day dude but just
cuz I haven't slept
so anyway I'm not trying to complain you
guys I'm a [ __ ] but yeah I guess I
just you know I think this place got me
feeling kind of emotional because my mom
went to college here and you know she
went to law school you know she did
stuff like that and um and then she had
four kids and she couldn't like you know
she probably couldn't use a lot of her
dreams and abilities that she wanted to
because she had to raise her kids you
know so I guess I feel
I guess I feel I don't feel like
responsible that she didn't get to like
do some of the things she wanted to do
but I feel um damn sitting yeah I guess
I feel like I don't feel like ashamed I
guess I feel like you know I feel like
she sacrificed for me so I want to be
able to you know just like not let her
down you know it so so you know I'm just
bonkers I didn't get to drive over there
and see to college because and it's only
20 minutes away and I've never even been
around here before
and I wanted to go so I just I don't
know man at the hip pop I'm just not
doing that well I mean I'm doing well
you know I just have like a lot of my
mind and like a lot of my heart so and
then I just you know I just like when I
get stressed out of stuff I don't handle
it that way you don't us I don't take
care of myself super good you know so I
come home last night and you know next
thing you know I'm like you know I'm
just so I'm just like I don't know if
I'm like disappointed I don't know what
are you but then I like you know I get
into the dark arts man I'll do Matt you
know I do you know I do masturbation or
whatever you know I'm out there jerking
out you know and it's just like and then
I just feel like just such a failure you
know do this nothing sad about when you
would do it and you this [ __ ] jerked
off you didn't want to damn bra that
[ __ ] will make you feel make you feel
kind of weak sometimes so but man so
many great people came out
ah I don't know if I should put this
episode out now I got myself all over
the place man
so many great people great people came
out we had fun you know we really had
fun uh let's get to a couple calls from
calls came in videos Kevin dude a lot of
stuff came in but thank you everybody
they came out in Raleigh Raleigh uh you
know just thank you to everybody came
out man I appreciate the support you
know man I saw trying to go through some
of the people that came out but we went
and saw the Andy Griffith statue at
Pullman Park that's one thing I was
trying to remember because I love Andy
Griffith and and I'm just saying one of
the things that makes me mad sometimes
and I say this kind of [ __ ] about
Hollywood it but they don't whereas the
storytellers that you know what I'm
saying
Hollywood will come to you know Atlanta
and they'll come to these different
cities in New Orleans and you know to
make these easy ass shows you know to
take advantage of you know you notice to
to get you know the best parts of us but
yeah they're not putting in any of the
storytellers out there on the stages
half the people I know in the south and
the Midwest in any small town I'm not
just being specific dude I'm not a
redneck people who Sam around not a
[ __ ] redneck dude I never had any of
that [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
that's but I'm I'm just from this from a
poor place I'm from a regular place and
everybody doesn't know their uncle or
their grandfather their great-uncle
could be one of the best storytellers of
all time so sometimes I guess you know
what I was saying about that makes me
mad sometimes about or I'm saying choose
you know find where your entertainment
is best is I get mad that I know that
there's you know I'm on the road and I
hear people start telling stories and
I'm like damn man can I have aa can I
have an element of that story this is
the greatest story I've ever heard but
instead I got to listen to some you know
late-night joke writer that somebody's
trying to turn into a you know who don't
any [ __ ] who's never lived through
anything and I got to listen to this
[ __ ] you know for 20 years
you're telling me you can't find
somebody from a rural part of America
who can entertain people you know
ton there's tons of them out there and
so that's what I'm saying as audience
members as people we needed we gotta
find you know if we take what they give
us all the time if we take that just you
know then that's where we're gonna be I
don't know
and now I'm [ __ ] preaching again I'm
sorry I'm [ __ ] sorry dude I'm sitting
here I'm under pants bro a little while
ago I got teared up you ever find
yourself getting teared up next you know
you why I'm literally wiping my eyes
with a dirty pair of socks [ __ ] it
they're yours do that [ __ ] you fired
yourself if you get on the phone you get
caught up and next thing you know you
look in your hand and you have like a
[ __ ] stapler or a pack of cheese or
something like what the [ __ ] you get
into that phone or that conversation
zone that twilight zone and next thing
you know you come to when you got you
know you got a couple of hot skittles in
your hand and you're like what the [ __ ]
I don't even eat candy but yeah man oh
there's a lot of magic in some of these
areas there's a lot of magic in places
like this in Raleigh and uh um Raleigh
reminds me of Raleigh Coleman my one of
my assistant principals man who had a
jheri curl and I'll say this right now
you know he had some african-american
fans that came out some you know some
black fans that came out this week and I
say it is one of my young bucks came out
this dude had a pic he had that afro and
I said look man you grow a jheri curl
you can open for me for the rest of your
life you know when I'm close to you you
can open for me for the rest of your
life man because I don't see why people
will grow to jheri curl
oh dude Rolly call me see hear that J
curl boy needs sleep in the trunk of his
car at recess man and he was the vice
president that dude would just cut off
and get him a little he'd have a little
you know split him up a little sandwich
a little cuts a ham or something you
know maybe a little thing of Delmonte
her can now they got all these snack
packs and Nissen and
oh you want the go-gurt squeeze go-gurt
in your mouth he's squeezing [ __ ]
packets of [ __ ] dairy in your mouth
dude what's wrong with you when I was
young you had that can boy my mom used
to send us to school with a can of
[ __ ] pears and no opener [ __ ]
you won't lunch yeah guy and a half to
iron it you know I'm saying next thing
you know I'm why I'm wandering around
school by the welding area by the Home
Economics you know I'm trying to get to
know somebody just so I can fill my
stomach now these kids got this snack
pants nine different flavors what that
came out come on man oh but yeah I don't
know man I guess I'm just frustrated and
then I get home and next thing you know
I'm just you know I just sometimes it
makes me I get upset with myself cuz I
don't have a lot of good processes like
daily routines in my life right now
because things have gotten pretty
erratic I don't have a lot of daily
routines right now usually I do and
right just the past month really they've
been slipping because of just just a lot
on the go and uh and so it just makes me
feel unsettled you know it's kind of
like having roller skate so when you got
your skates on you going around the rink
it kind of makes sense but right now I
feel like I'm still going around the
rink but I don't have my skates on but
I'm still going around the rink so it's
weird cuz I'm still going I don't have
my skates you know so just got to get my
skates you know just got to get my
skates g'd up yeah let's cut a call or
two man here's uh here's one that came
in right here this is Brandon from
Tennessee so had a little car trouble
and my bearing broke in the middle of a
busy intersection what'd I tell you
about the compassionate this guy had for
me okay so you had a car broke in the
busy intersection do
dude I'll tell you this one time I was
in an automobile and it was my own and
it was a Ford Escort bro and it didn't
even have a passenger seat so I had that
car if you came to pick somebody up and
they got in in the passenger side they
had to just walk directly into the back
it was a Ford or a Ford Escort boy the
Gray Goose been in countless accidents
dude you know I'm saying if you had a
nice car sometimes if I saw a rich
person's a nice car parked at night my
car was all [ __ ] up I just hit their
[ __ ] car boy hood I'll [ __ ]
checkmate baby you know I'm saying a
little bit of headlight haki daddy you
know a little bit of smooch bro a little
bit of panel [ __ ] a little bit of
side panel sex baby cuz I got nothing to
lose this Ford Escort cost me thirteen
hundred babe a bang bang and I keep the
plates in the back seat but uh but
anyway what happened to me was one time
my car ran out of gas because I've run
out of gas countless times probably 3040
times I didn't know you that people
didn't run out of gas and my car ran out
of gas and then the next thing you know
I'm listening to the football game so I
need to get help because I need to get
help to get the car to the road but the
game was at a crucial moment so I stayed
there in a busy intersection dude and
ruin people's lives for probably another
30 minutes brought calls sheer Hellfire
and that's just because the New Orleans
Saints was doing all right
and so I enjoyed that moment but go on
oh they saw that broke down I came out
and helped and he let me borrow Jack and
obviously he's my bad news repre
couldn't get out of the road cops came
they called a tow truck and you know
even a little time here lately so the
tow truck was $175 yeah tow truck B and
they're expensive man so you're there
the tow truck shows up sorry I was on my
phone too for a second but I got to go
the show's starting in four minutes and
I'm have to leave in a few minutes and
and then I'll try to come back and do a
little bit more the episode you guys
won't know that because I'm just gonna
you know it'll be all together by the
time I post it but anyhow
anyhow you stranded out there you got
this $175 toe thing and tow trucks you
charging too much you know that [ __ ]
don't you you know it I mean you know it
though right
homeward and that you had just met
he he he walked up this truck comes back
up to me and there's a water catchment
and he puts in my hand gives me a hug
because I manage her lucky day
he gave me $180 pissed okay and now
they're just really resonated with me
man like just the kindness is that that
guy that's this stranger so I don't know
I just wanted to share my story and it
really got me thinking I'm gonna have to
pay that board and now I just want to
spread kindness and love to a lot of
other people oh that doesn't happen
every day and they still get people in
this club yeah hey man uh I'm gonna
continue in Nashville alleged man thanks
man I proceeded to tell me that story
you know my story made me feel good you
know that man went got a wad of cash and
came back and gave it to you
180 you know and he didn't leave you at
175 he just you know he knew there might
be tax he knew there might be a little
wiggle room maybe get you a little soda
after you know maybe you get over there
and get your little pineapple soda if
they're selling something at the tow
truck place or whatever because you know
those [ __ ] sell some weird [ __ ]
at tow truck places do come out have a
[ __ ] cherry cheesecake [ __ ] y'all
doing towing now you got these $3
[ __ ] hits a [ __ ] cheesecake which
all doing selling pineapple sodas out
here they can you're weird at a tow
truck facility but man that's crucial
you know you had a crucial moment there
where somebody made you feel good and
now here's the challenge I find for me
here's that here's my challenge here's
my here here here's the challenge for me
somebody does something good for me and
I say oh man I'm gonna do something for
somebody else and then you know what I
go right back to being who I was I go
right back to forget
I get you know my faith falls apart my
faith even in just that I'm gonna be
that different person he said we got to
practice it man
we got to practice it whatever it is you
know they say faith without works is
dead and it's true you know and I think
maybe that's important you know not to
bring it back to me but that's something
I've been feeling it's just so funny you
call about this because I just feel like
you know I have my faith but I'm just
not working in as much and that doesn't
mean in it doesn't just mean a faith in
a higher power but that means a faith in
anything a faith in myself a faith in
you know my morning practices my morning
routines of faith in that my behavior is
gonna be consistent if I don't work it
it is not gonna be that way but man it
sounds like not only did he give you
$180 but he gave you he
you an idea he gave you a hope he gave
you something that can grow you know he
gave you uh man it feels good man it you
know what's crazy about doing something
good for somebody you telling me that
story right there that just that story
made me feel good that story made me
feel good and it didn't even happen to
me I mean that's the power I thought
that's powerful
and I don't just say this shit's
powerful I can feel it you don't just
feel [ __ ] that isn't real you know so on
a very emotional episode of this past
weekend thank you for calling them man
and putting that out there
180 bucks that's a lot you know it's a
lot dude that's like three hours of
sleep in this hotel room and dude this
[ __ ] thing they got a clock over
there it's not even set on regular time
they have one clock on regular time and
another clock on a different [ __ ]
time that's when you know it's a fancy
hotel room when they got one clock shows
you what time it is then another clock
just doing its own [ __ ] thing you
know what I'm saying it's 7:30 in the
evening right now it's 7:31
and then they got a clock over there
says it's 11:00 a.m. that [ __ ]
[ __ ] on vacation and that's when you
know the hotel room is nice they got
four different kinds of soap in there
one of them for your face bro and one of
them's for your body what you telling me
these [ __ ] can't work together
to him you know it's expensive hotel
room when they got soap beef they out
any [ __ ] Sud streets these [ __ ]
can't get along down here spitting bars
broad dish tracks
dropping bars bars they got them dirty
bars and they are bars [ __ ] y'all are
soaps okay face [ __ ] shoulders
whatever you know what I'm saying get it
too
other y'all need to team up and work
together man life is too short for one
of y'all to be doing above the neck and
one of y'all below and one of y'all
doing only behind you no legs so what's
next huh
what's next leg soap what is next
that [ __ ] a little elbow special bar
team up and work together man that's the
kind of [ __ ] you get in these fancy
hotel rooms you know too much it's too
much all right I gotta go do this comedy
set and I'll be back in just a little
bit man you won't know it because you
guys are just listening you know you
won't know it but I'll know it I'm gonna
go get in a car and drive over there
then I'll come back and finish up this
episode I love you all right and I don't
know why I'm telling you that but just
in case something happens to me or it's
not gonna but you know I got to drive
over there and I am in a [ __ ] Miata
or not no I'm liking a Ford Ford viagra
or something
I don't know this thing mmm you could
feel the car being scared about hitting
a bump when you're driving it that's how
little this little rental is but uh I'll
talk to you in a few minutes
today's episode is also brought to you
by go yah Yas crepes and coffee and that
is a local establishment down there in
Baton Rouge Louisiana and my whole
family my brother lives down there in
Baton Rouge and his son little Zephie
just had her birthday yesterday and they
live right over there by the Chase Bank
but go Yaya's is a beautiful place they
have crepes and coffee think about a
crepe
now think about yourself man come on
that'd be a beautiful relationship
wouldn't it go go yeah go Yaya's excuse
me is just five minutes from LSU they're
serving breakfast and lunch they have
sweet crepes they have breakfast crepes
bacon egg and cheese crepes chorizo and
eggs with that South's affair
yeah they got lunch california turkey
club with avocado is that a crepe in
your pants or you just happy a nice um
they're open monday to friday 7 a.m. to
1:30 p.m.
only in Baton Rouge Louisiana downtown
501 Main Street go yah yah scrapes and
coffee open for lunch and breakfast and
other meals get that hitter alright guys
and I'm back uh so I had a great time at
the show we just went and got it done
and I want to thank everybody else that
came out I got to show you guys this man
I didn't tell you some of the things
well first I got to tell you this man
you know and I talked about it briefly I
did like a preface at the beginning of
this episode like I left my you know cuz
I I just I've been feeling kind of
strange man you know and part of it is
um you know part of it there's a lot
going on and at the same time part of it
is uh that I left my medicine in Los
Angeles and I take medication you know I
take a light dose of antidepressants and
and I left him in LA and that was on
Thursday so I didn't take him on
Thursday didn't take him on Friday
didn't take him on Saturday no I came
here Friday so anyway whatever today's
Sunday so today's that third day and I'm
just not feeling you know I'm just
feeling a little more emo Nemo you know
I'm just feeling a little I got them BAM
I got a little bit of Bambi legs and
mice in my soul I got the mammy legs
baby I got them you know Bambi had legs
just like those just like you know like
there's fresh harp strings you know just
uncertain just like those fresh you know
like them just like those fresh violin
strings like if suddenly somebody added
two new strings to the violin even the
strings would be like oh [ __ ] what do we
do you know and uh and so you know you
got those Bambi legs as you know the
shaky makers and so that's kind of how
I'm feeling
no I just feel a little bit shaky and
I'm already kind of a little bit of like
I eat oh sorry mails on I'm already kind
of a little bit of like a emo Nemo and
you know I'm always kind of swimming in
my feelings a little bit and I'm fine
with that
you know I don't fear my feelings
in fact I welcome them but but you know
sometimes I get you know when I'm not
when I don't have I haven't taken my
medicine over a period of time it makes
me feel you know it just it's a change
and so I'm still fine but you know it is
makes you feel a little bit just it
makes me feel a little unsure of myself
so anyhow it's not like a disclaimer or
anything really but I just
yeah I'm just feeling exhausted too you
know I just feel really really exhausted
it's just been a long couple of weeks
but going to China coming back you know
I haven't been eating much you know
people say you're getting skinny and um
there's nothing wrong with me
I just haven't been I haven't I've been
working you know I've just been working
a lot so I need to start taking a little
bit better care of myself right now and
uh and see what's going on with me and
I'm gonna do that and I'm gonna start
doing that I hate to say it but by just
I'm gonna cut this episode down you know
I'm gonna wish a happy birthday to my
friend bill and he turned 44 and you
know he gots two daughters and a wife
and they just got a female cat at the
house so I mean he's [ __ ] you know but
um but I'm glad to have friends like him
you know I just had to call my brother
and just kind of check in with some
people after the show tonight I just I
don't know I just need to get some rest
you know we did have some cool videos
that came in I'm gonna I'm gonna do one
or two or three of those because I love
those oh I wanted to show you what
somebody brought me people brought a lot
of nice stuff you know the Harvard lady
that called in that teacher that
Professor she brought me a nice book and
I'm gonna read that soon but somebody
brought brought me these I'll put a
picture on my Instagram as well
straight up hampster skulls okay and a
skull it's like a
it's like the Lord put your brain in
like a hard gift bag for the world it's
like you like it the Lord put your brain
and like a hard to go sack and and
before the you know before he let it go
out into the world and that's your skull
and these are real hamp skulls and
honestly to me they look like gee pig
skulls they look a little more G pick
because these are pretty grandiose
looking but they have tattooed there
they're branded up the skulls are one of
them says onward and one of them says
Rat King and man look and look no
pressure if anybody bring you don't to
compete with this guy's you know people
you know drop off different things
sometimes and sometimes I give gifts to
people that come out but my hands yeah
man you telling me to G pigs out there
to give up their life so daddy could
have these [ __ ] wild hitters well
that's what the Lord wants man that's
what the Lord wants so but oh and they
have n stuff written inside of them what
does this one don't pet Oh don't pet the
Playboy and then it says Gang Gang right
or Emma
wherever the spine we go into it damn
boy this is the dark arts literally this
is arts and speaking of the dark arts
man I'm gonna play a video right now
somebody sent in a video you know they
doing graffiti out there in the streets
and let's take a video right now this is
from Nick Smith and if you're watching
on the YouTube you can see the video
how's it going feel we're out here at
the graffiti wall just painted this guy
out here practicing them Dark Arts gang
sometimes the dark arts are good
sometimes they're not but regardless
we're out here who are doing what we can
onward
Wow so this is graffiti look you guys
can't see it
somebody graffiti the whole side of a
building and it says the dark arts and
then it says onward 2018 that's Nessie
in esy
and maybe I shouldn't give him the
dude's name because I don't know if this
is illegal or not but this looks like a
nice business he said it's the graffiti
wall and his dark arts you can see it on
YouTube and this is I'm not this itted
in a couple square feet this is about
looks like about a 30 by 12 foot mural
so gang gang maybe get out there and
it's classy work - I mean that is just
real class he worked that's something
look if you could hang the whole side of
a building on refrigerator your mother
would do just that Nick Smith so thank
you for being out there and for doing
that
let's take we'll hit a couple more these
video lines man here we go
onward hey what's up Theo it's Justin
from New Jersey I've been a huge fan for
a while I always used to thank you or
the comic in the world honestly but
thanks Justin Matthews for the the nice
words man you know um you know I'll say
this about being under radar feeling
underrated it's uh there's a blessing
there because you don't the expectations
aren't there you know when nobody knows
you
the only person expecting anything out
of you is you and some people were you
know may have you know dreams or
ambitions in their life and they're like
man I'm not as known as I want to be
here I don't have the platform that I
want let's say that but man that is a
beautiful place to be in because you can
because you are in it you're doing
you're working you're doing your work
you're doing your work and and that's a
beautiful place to be it's doing your
work because that's the only thing is
that's the only thing that means
anything it really is your what are you
doing what are you doing and not
necessarily output but that could be
emotional work connecting what do you
are you doing you work so and then
whenever you get to a place where you're
ready for when the platform arrives you
know when that boat arrives you want to
be able to get into the boat if you
never you don't know how you don't know
how a boat works and you just standing
there staring at a boat cuz you're not
boat about you don't have that boat
ability building here into your system
come on you're done you're just gonna be
a bank baby
so so you know when you're waiting for
that boat to arrive when you're you know
you're hoping you're hoping for a
platform you're hoping for you know uh
you know whether it's an artwork or uh
you know you like to speak or you like
to perform or you like to you just want
to be in love you know you just want to
be happy whatever those things are that
you're building towards it's nice
whenever nobody when you don't have that
is it's kind of nice when that boat
isn't standing there waiting for you
because then you got a produce then you
got to do it you know you got to have
then it's not um you know or at least it
feels like a pressure then and maybe
that could be me to just feeling weird
pressures I don't know what I'm talking
about Justin um or let's hear more from
you man and thank you for this video but
I don't say that anymore because I think
you're finally getting the recognition
you deserve but my question is I'm a
musician I've done 14 tours I'm on the
road four or five months out of the year
wow that's a lot homeward and I'm in
that I'm in a as well and thank you for
sharing man I know it's a you know it's
not something that sometimes we share
some people believe you shouldn't share
if you're an AAA and here's why and I'll
say why and understand it don't share it
because what if somebody hears you say
and I'm not calling you out Justin I'll
share it so you know people say well you
shouldn't share that deal because what
if somebody listens to you and they get
into a program but then you decide the
program isn't for you and you get out
and now they think or what if somebody's
thinking about getting into the program
then they see that oh well he did the
program
didn't work for him or the poor he got
out I don't need to go now
and uh and so in understand that you
know I'm a little [ __ ] cuz I already
said it so I got a you know I have to
live here on the on the on the land of
my words but all more Justin let's hear
about your question homeward I'm in the
I'm in a as well and I wanted to know as
an entertainer yourself how do you stay
sober and you know stick to the 12 steps
and stick to you know everything you've
learned on the road especially being in
clubs and stuff with alcohol because I'm
doing the same thing I'm proud to say
that I've done I think 14 tours 13 of
them I was drunk the entire time but my
last one I just did
I stayed completely sober it wasn't easy
I don't think I was doing it correctly I
was kind of wait not going it a bit but
if you have any tips that'd be great
thank you well you know what happened to
me I'll just tell you tonight so tonight
I was in a tough spot man I was in a
tough spot when I started this podcast
earlier I wasn't feeling good you know I
just wasn't feeling good I mean you know
I don't have my don't have a you know I
don't have a nerd prescient you know I'm
on that ldz baby I'm on that light dose
but I didn't have it and you know Wow
but what I did was I ended up calling a
friend of mine I called a friend who I
met oh well I met through the program
and we can talk about whatever you know
I called my friend and we just we
laughed we laughed about partying we
laughed about his family we laughed
about he told me one time he had missed
his antidepressants and he was on the
road and he was so [ __ ] banked out
about it he went to the emergency room
okay and the people at the emergency
room they charged him $1,200 for ten
pills generic okay we took a [ __ ] that
would cost you seven dollars usually so
we laughed about that and so next and
that's a friend I met through a a kinda
you know who's in the program so next
thing you know I have a friend
and I don't feel alone because for me a
lot of times what it is is just some
sort of loneliness that you know it
starts to manifest when I'm on the road
so I keep in close contact for me
fortunately people come out now that are
in the program you know a young man came
today and invited me to a meeting last
night invited me to a meeting you know I
went to a meeting the last city I was in
we went to a meeting somewhere in
Shanghai we I've gone to some meetings
in other places so it's you know it's
nice that you can you know that's one
thing that I like about it is now I'm
not alone maybe I have to say that
sometimes maybe I have to announce it
sometimes there say because I need to
save my [ __ ] program you know but as
for the steps man I don't know I haven't
gone through the steps you know I'm not
all the way through you know and I know
and so you know I don't know you know I
don't know what I know some of the stuff
that keeps me from getting through is
fear you know not wanting to be fully
honest with myself probably about stuff
probably fears that are hidden inside of
me that I can't even access or that I'm
afraid to you know but my friends remind
me a lot that I need to or they trying
to be supportive and asking me about it
but but yeah what do i do on the road I
mean I stay busy you know what I still
do I hit my knees in the morning and I
say the serenity prayer and even if I
don't remember it for the rest of the
day I know that it was there with me in
the beginning and and I don't put myself
in precarious situations you know I mean
I know the temps from the temptations
for me sometimes is you know I'll be
okay if a dude as we want to go party
I'm okay but a wild woman shows up or
somewhat Eightball and daddy might feel
tempted you know and that's when the
dark hearts just start spray-painting my
[ __ ] soul bruh you know III got a I
got um I got Picasso down D you know I
got that dirty Picasso down deep in me
dark art so I don't know if that answers
the question or not but I what I do do
is I keep in touch with friends and I
get texts constantly and that's one of
the reasons I just want to get home and
get back into my program again so I have
my
[ __ ] roller skates on because
otherwise I'm just slipping around on
some sliding shoes bra and I that ain't
me I need my wheels in a row but thank
you for checking in Justin we're gonna
take one more video that came here man
and then I'm gonna shut it down for
tonight here we go high field there's
also guy greetings from Dubai I'm a
Swedish dude living in Dubai dang this
is all scar and I'll scare we call it
Oscar - and they some people say aw
scare and I like that oh you are you
Terrance no I'm Terrance are you Frank
I'm f rank baby you know are you uh are
you um are you mark nah I am mmm
[Music]
you know I'm saying you can switch your
name up in this st. Oscar maybe this is
Oscar a Swedish man in Dubai so you're
doing all sorts of things maybe your
[ __ ] human buffet big boy let's hear
more I scared thank you for calling your
podcast and I want to ask a question I'm
a public speaker and I have a podcast
and I realized that the best paid
speakers are actually the ones that are
including humor in the
speaking and in the podcast okay so the
best paid speakers he's saying are the
ones including humor and their speaking
and their podcasts more a scare I want
to do that in my when I speak I want to
be a little bit more funny
so how can you become more funnier when
I give my talks what what any resources
to make become more funnier and you
should come visit us in the bar check
out these cool looks do Beach that is
beautiful thank you for showing me that
scenery and if you could see the video
all scare is out there by the beach and
he's standing they got a bus going by in
the background and it also looks like
his car might be broke down out there
but um how can you be funnier man you
know what I'm what I try to keep tabs on
for me is I just see when people one
other when I make other people laugh I
want to make other people smile or I
make them feel you know they drop in
they're listening they're paying
attention
dude to me I'll scare you have a very
nice you have a nice disposition your
sweetest bro so for a lot of people
anything you even say is gonna be fun
interesting or funny I mean even just
your name you know I started laughing
about your name I started clowning you
about your name right out the gate cuz
to me in America that name is Oscar but
when you say all-sky like damn boy you
know I'm Sam [ __ ] first I was having
soup and now I'm having ratatouille
you just [ __ ] upgrade in my whole
world just with that little tilt to
[ __ ] that little tongue tilt you got
and that's that natus that's that that
that natural Swedish build in that's
natural
so do you can talk about probably very
regular things very basic stuff to
people that are not Swedish it's gonna
be funny because you know you can think
of yourself as an instrument you know I
noticed some people think that it's fun
you know a southern accent you can they
say you can get away with a lot of stuff
because you have a southern accent well
it yeah okay if that's how you feel then
that's my instrument maybe my voice
whatever it is it's my instrument
I think you got a neat instrument man
but I would pay attention when you're
talking to people if people laugh if
people find some joy and also the goal
sometimes isn't to tell a joke but the
goal sometimes is just to tell a story
and listen to the story where people
laugh and then you can go back and make
more jokes in those places and those are
just my thoughts all scared I may not
know what they [ __ ] I'm it's how can
mount but we'll get to some more next
week man guys I'm sorry to shut it down
but it's you know it's gonna take me in
another hour and a half to put this
thing together and to send it back to
Los Angeles and then I have a flight at
7 a.m. and I got to return this rental
car and I know I'm complaining but my
chest just feels tight and I just gotta
rest
you know I just need a rest and uh and
I'm grateful man so many great people
came up this week and I wish I can t
remember all the kind people that came
out I mean I remember him but I just
wish I knew them all by name you know
and it means a lot you know you know I
see you know it just means a lot you
know it means a lot that uh that I'm
just able to be a part of something neat
and that we're making people laugh and I
you know I promise to just try and keep
doing my work you know to stay out of
the expectations if I can I mean that's
another thing I think out of Scott you
know a lot of this is new to me where
people are coming out you know when you
work hard and you do the work over the
years and you I don't know if you ever
think it's you know you know payoff you
always wish you had more time to prepare
for anything you know but you know I
know that my audience I know that people
that come out and you know people that
listen to the podcast and stuff I know
that you know I never feel really judged
you know I don't feel a lot of judgment
I feel a lot of you know support really
and so you know I guess some of those
feelings of sodomy are just they're
misguided they're not real you know some
of those aren't real and some of those
are just fears and some of them some of
them are because I haven't had my
medicine in three days and so those
things are way easier to creep up into
my system and into my into the natural
foreground of my mental
'but at but but again today's episode
brought to you by gray block pizza
today's episode brought to you by beard
brand and we got that free sea salt
spray and we'll put that link below if
you want to get involved with those cats
man and they got good items and we'll
put the link below to them
today's intro music was by Jameson flood
and he's a beautiful guy and he's come
out to see the shows over the years and
we've become buddies and he made that
every night every night I lie awake I
feel like a fake I put on a show
you know and some of that's fear man
some of that's just you know that's the
dark arts that's the devil using your
own brain cells against you you know
it's tough when you feel like you're
doing you know you feel like a good
person but then you feel like you you
aren't a good person it's just such a
weird place to be in and I think I just
I'm just overwhelmed with anxiety and
it's a lot of different things you know
just a lot just a lot this week we have
what else oh I'll tell you this we got
some dates coming up I'll be in
Minneapolis August 4th oh that might be
sold out August 16th through the 18th
Chicago then I'll be in Nashville
Toronto let's make them pop out there
Canada we're gonna do it all let's put
it on them September 20th through the
24th and just for laughs
go get them whatever how they set it up
somewhere where you got to get armbands
and [ __ ] you got to pick me so it's
some probably scandal or whatever I
don't know but you know how these people
are but I'll be there and I'll happily
be there Appleton Wisconsin Salt Lake
City Washington DC other places I'll see
you those you can see all of those so on
Theo von comm store we got Rat King
shirts going out this week Theo von Dom
slash store and theof Anka stockholm
slash store as well thank you go Yaya's
down there in Baton Rouge go get them
crepes go get them coffee it's 501 Main
Street downtown
get them hitters thank you everybody
that came out of Raleigh
I'm sorry to cut it off early guys I
feel bad I felt like I'm not doing my
job but I feel like I got also I got to
get myself you know kind of a little bit
well tonight so I can continue to do my
job moving forward and we can just keep
making things do cool stuff thank you to
the single mom it came out Nancy thank
you to the patreon people who helped
support that and make that happen thank
you to the staff at a goodnights oh you
know one thing I'll say man this was
really cool I was at the Pullman parked
down there visiting that Andy Griffith
statue and Rowley and and you know for
all this media attention I hear about
racism and all of this [ __ ] and [ __ ]
idiots on Twitter and all of this dude
I'm in a park in US and what you would
call the South even though it starts
with the North you know people like it's
the south I'm like it's North Carolina
so yeah I'm a woman Oh check your uh you
know I don't know what it's called the
word that comes before the your
adjectives brother but um and there was
a lot of it was a you know what kind of
a black and white city it feels like to
me and man it felt like there was a lot
less racial tension than there was when
I grew up in a similar type of a black
and white environment and that's just my
opinion I don't live here you know I
don't know what it's like all the time
but I'll tell you this I saw families
walking around enjoying each other's
company
I saw people looking each other in the
eyes there were different races and not
you know not looking with fear or
inferiority and man it was do I'll tell
you this it was different than the park
when I walked around in the park growing
up it was different and it was better
and it felt [ __ ] comfortable man and
you know and I did that kind of [ __ ]
it's like let's look at the truth so
what's it are going on and the truths
are I think that people we're gonna be
fine you know we just lay off this
clickbait you know but I love you guys
man I'm sorry if I'm preaching man I'm
[ __ ] I'm not doing super well but I
love you and
good yourselves you probably deserve it
you know that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's every night right there by
Jamison flood we'll put a link to that
one so you can check it out be good to
your cells man you probably deserve it
and thank you guys I'll talk to you soon
[Music]